the fact is pulling out of the Iran deal
was the right move plain and simple and
I can't wait to see what Trump has
planned here to give us insight is
citizen journalist and master tactician
Tim balls break it down for me Tim what
is Trump's plan it's quite simple Jordan
Obama created the nuclear deal by
pressuring Iran through sanctions to
come to the table so weak but Trump will
make a nuclear deal by pressuring Iran
through sanctions to come to the table
so strong totally strong does sound a
bit similar
what no get your ass out of your ears
Jordan we're in a way better position
now we have zero allies supporting us so
America will get all the credit when we
achieve peace or war or whatever it's
brilliant Jordan hold my beer that bub
ten we talked about drinking at work no
no Jordan that's the name of the
strategy and it's one of Tim's tactics
toons tactics hold my beer hold my beers
a tactic I learned in college it's the
belief that no matter what someone else
did you can do better probably drunk
with zero experience Obama thought he
was so cool for this Iran deal but Trump
knows he can do it way better
Trump's like the guy at the party who
saw someone cannonball into the pool
then climbed up on the roof and is like
I can make it I swear
and now John Bolton and Mike Pompeo are
chanting jump jump jump
so he's jumping and he can figure out
why this was a great decision as he
plummets toward the hard unforgiving
concrete vats hold my beer diplomacy
yeah is that how you broke both of your
legs last spring no I broke both my legs
trying to jump my jet ski into the set
of MTV's the grind before I realized
they canceled that show in 1997 look all
Obama ever did is create stuff but Trump
is destroying stuff which is way harder
and it lasts way longer the Paris
climate Accords hold my beer trade
partnerships hold my beer Obamacare hold
my beer and take a sip because that's
the only medicine you can afford now and
you think I won't get drunk at work hold
my beer
Tim Tim please please please stop Tim
Tim no you don't have to you don't you
no no you don't have to finish that oh
oh oh you don't think I can finish this
hold my beer oh no please
[Applause]
[Music]